seems that when it comes to women's
rights originalist perspective tends to
sight on the air of always Looking
Backward backward and not looking at
current day because they're trying to
because if you're looking if I wrote a
piece of legislation 10 years ago and I
said to you okay are you and I write a
piece of legislation today and we use
the language of today we mean something
by that language in this conversation
somebody will read this 100 years from
now and we will have met what we're
saying to each other we understand what
we're saying if somebody wants to read
what we're talking about today and then
it turns out that all the words that
we're using now mean the reverse because
things have changed did our conversation
mean the reverse of what it meant or
does it mean what we're talking about
right now words have meaning at the time
they are said to try and read new
meanings into Old words just because
quote unquote times have changed you can
end up with some really bizarre and
let's talk about the rights about most
women didn't want the right to vote
because of the responsibilities that
came with the right to vote and so
feminism has always been about the
freedoms without the responsibilities
always always